[Música]
hace un mes se sacudió la tierra en
Siria y Turquía los terremotos que son
los peores en la zona de las últimas
décadas dejaron a más de 50.000
fallecidos y miles de edificios en
ruinas la situación de los desplazados
sigue siendo crítica aún así revienta
giberto gane sostiene que no aplazará
las elecciones en Turquía y bashara
lazada en Siria permanece indemne
analizamos con Lucía siriani ella es el
licenciada de tecnología y doctorante
del programa en estudios islámicos de la
universidad libre de Berlín también es
miembro del grupo de estudios sobre
eurasia Muchas gracias Lucía por estar
en directo América
gracias por la invitación comienzo
preguntándole por la situación en
Turquía está en capacidad del país de
sostener elecciones con normalidad como
ya lo reitero erdogan pensando además
que los comicios cuestan dinero cuando
se requieren fondos o para aliviar a los
sobrevivientes
no con normalidad no Incluso se declaró
un estado de excepción en las once
provincias que fueron afectadas por el
terremoto pero lo cierto Es que parece
que ninguna de las partes quiere aplazar
más las elecciones
las encuestas que se han hecho tanto en
los sitios afectados como en las
regiones no afectadas por el terremoto
son que tanto las personas afines al
gobierno como la oposición prefieren que
las elecciones sean ya lo más pronto
posible y no y no quieren aplazar este
los comicios Usted cree que esta era la
mejor apuesta de erdogan mantener la
fecha de elecciones ya ha pedido Perdón
en varias oportunidades por esta lenta
respuesta del gobierno tras los
terremotos y hace dos décadas llegó al
poder además prometiendo que iba a ser
reformas para que tragedias como esta no
volvieran a suceder algo que no terminó
de pasar
si yo creo que es la mejor oportunidad
que tiene el gobierno porque aunque
todavía no se refleja que su popularidad
haya bajado incluso creció un poco muy
poco pero creció un poco la popularidad
del gobierno actual tras el terremoto
casi todos los analistas que están allá
calculan que cuando la atención cambia
de la población afectada del Duelo hacia
la ira por las responsabilidades de
quienes están en el gobierno por la
situación Entonces sí se podría ver
afectado electoralmente el partido de
justicia y desarrollo Entonces
definitivamente es ahora que más le
conviene al gobierno de Don llevar a
cabo estas elecciones bien y además de
recordar que para hoy estaban previstos
varios anuncios de la oposición que se
ha visto fragmentada y pues el candidato
que tendría que enfrentarse a erdogan
pero ahora pasemos un poco a Siria por
favor Le pido porque entre tanto Vimos
abachar a la sala en las noticias
hablando con representantes de la ONU
hablando con la Cruz Roja para negociar
el paso de ayuda a las zonas afectadas
que están dominadas por los Rebeldes
opositores Que tanto se convirtieron en
hechos esos apretones de mano de
guachara las hadas para las cadenas
internacionales
en términos generales las noticias que
tenemos sobre Siria son las tenemos que
tomar con pinzas son un poquito menos
claras sobre todo en lo que se refiere a
esa región porque no es muy claro lo que
el gobierno decidió pueda lograr justo
en la zona más afectada porque es la
zona que está bajo mayor control Rebelde
lo que todavía queda con control Rebelde
Entonces yo sobre esa región lo que
diría es que muchas de las afirmaciones
que tiene el gobierno tienen más
motivaciones políticas o geopolíticas
que lo que tiene que ver con concretar
la ayuda a la llegada al terreno pero si
nos queda claro que aún con el mundo
Mirando bachar al azar no tuvo problema
en efectuar bloqueos para el ingreso de
convoyes a las zonas más afectadas de
Siria porque sin embargo ya no se
concentra occidente en las acciones de
bachar a las después de que la guerra
civil ha estado en las noticias y en los
titulares durante años
yo creo que ahorita la principal la
atención de accidente está en resolver
la crisis que tienen en Ucrania y tienen
menos preocupación por el control de la
situación en Siria creo que eso es
principalmente la razón por la cual
ahorita no hay mucho este foco en lo que
está sucediendo en esa región en Siria
claro se retira entonces la
responsabilidad de esa parte Mientras
tanto hablemos un poco ahora por favor
Lucía de las de las tareas de
recuperación un mes después Cuál es la
realidad que usted ve en las zonas
afectadas
pues la situación es muy precaria y es
difícil predecir cómo se va a componer
en el caso de Siria como ya lo mencioné
antes el principal problema es la
fragmentación de la autoridad que hay
sobre estos terrenos o las zonas más
afectadas
este que no todas las zonas están bajo
control del gobierno
y del gobierno sirio entonces pues es
más difícil prever cómo se va a
organizar la transición ahí no la
recuperación respecto a Turquía pues la
promesa que también tiene funciones
electorales es la reconstrucción lo más
rápido posible de las de los edificios
afectados pero pues hay poca poca
discusión debido a la censura que han
tenido los medios que han querido hablar
acerca de las dimensiones negativas de
lo sucedido Hay muy poca atención sobre
las responsabilidades y las causas por
las cuales se magnificó el efecto de
terremoto no la situación de las malas
construcciones de la falta de
regulaciones o de aplicación de las
regulaciones para la construcción y
sobre todo tres problemas que dieron
lugar a que creciera tanto la tragedia
en Turquía es la aplicación no solo de
malas construcciones y de alteraciones
ilegales después de que ya se habían
terminado las construcciones sino lo le
llaman las amnistías de construcción eso
es la legalización de construcciones
irregulares por el la vía del pago de
una de una tarifa al gobierno para
regularizarlas en el papel aunque no
cumplieran con los requisitos ese último
es el aspecto que ha sido más señalado
por los expertos Entonces
es difícil con esas condiciones prever
qué tan eficiente podría ser la una
reconstrucción responsable no este y
hasta dónde pueden llegar los fondos
recibidos del extranjero
y sin embargo se habla de que serán
muchos años de reconstrucción gracias a
usted Lucía cirian y licenciada en
etnología y doctorante en estudios
islámicos de la universidad libre de
Berlín Le deseo que tenga un feliz día
Igualmente muchas gracias a nuestros
televidentes sigan en directo América ya
volvemos con más
[Música]